were you were you around when uh david
blaine did that stunt in london where he
would like
live in the caves yeah stayed in the
cage or something for like
how long did he stay in there for i
remember wasn't it yeah it was a long
time
it was like a month without any food or
something
and i remember just thinking there were
there were so many moments during that
month where
you just got [ __ ] [ __ ] on by all like
the [ __ ] chavs and
everything right that felt so bad
because like it was back in the time
when you know england had this
nice prim and proper image to americans
especially and
you just had like these [ __ ] people
like these londoners who were just
chucking paintballs at him and [ __ ] like
this
it felt so bad
man just like as well like when i saw
that he's like staying in there for 30
days i'm like
why why like i is the record really
worth it like i get it like the stunt
but like is this
is this is this fun i mean i guess the
fact that we're still talking about it
to this day is worth it right
true i guess that's the point right like
i just
lose a month in my life to get a bit of
clout
to be talked about the ultimate clout
chaser
i'm kidding i'm kidding this shit's very
impressive you're pretty kelly with
magic
make a frog come out of my ass
[ __ ] out frogs have you seen his ted
talk
uh no so he had a ted talk uh like
breaking down how he did one of his
stunts
uh which was like how he stayed
underwater and like broke the world
record
yeah yeah and like he was going through
the process
of like they tried a load of different
things like they tried stuffing like
um like an airbag into their stomach to
give him like a breathing tube and that
just
not just cheating yeah that's not just i
just know it's magic that just ended up
horribly
other than they just kind of like tried
a lot of different ways to
see if this was possible and then he
they just
like the conclusion they came to was
just let's just [ __ ] do it properly
so yeah he's just you know trained yeah
let's just let's just almost drown
myself
and uh that's basically what he did and
it's just like
man this is this this man has just
monetized being [ __ ] mental right
yeah
like it's true
it's respectable that he did that and he
achieved that like doesn't
like all the credit to him but my god
you must
it's it's the magic of willpower that's
cool [ __ ] craziest people that do
like the [ __ ] like
uh most of the [ __ ] [ __ ] that like you
know you have to be a little bit crazy
to be a genius i think you know what i
mean like that i think that has to be a
little bit yeah
right because i mean what was that quote
again is like a
a genius is just an insane person with
an audience
i don't know who said that quote
and i just my god yeah i don't know it's
like going back to the caving stuff we
saw a few weeks ago right it's like yeah
like it has to some there's got to be
some dopamine deficiency going on here
that requires you to like need to like
i'm like i have a good meal and i'm like
damn that dopamine hit was good
someone's like someone has like a
7-eleven like no i gotta [ __ ] climb
the building yeah i gotta
i gotta climb this 7-eleven it's gonna
hit
you're like what what's going on